american pickers is a classic staple of
reality tv
the history series has been around since
2010 and featured friends
more on this later frank fritz and mike
wolf traveling around the country buying
antiques and selling them for a tidy
profit
the business within a show where all of
the action happens is known as antique
archaeology
antenna colby runs the whole operation
while fritz and wolf seek out all those
juicy profitable treasures that fans
eagerly tune
in to see season 22 started up with a
new cast member
jersey john and not frank joining mike
on his back road adventures the whole
issue boiled over into public view
after fritz confirmed that he would not
be returning to american pickers
despite concluding his stint in rehab to
treat alcohol addiction
in that same bombshell interview fritz
divulged that he and wolf had not spoken
in years
even though he described their previous
relationship as close enough to finish
each other's sentences
wolfe later added fuel to the fire of
speculation with a social media post
that confirmed fritz would not be
returning to american pickers that
announcement was couched in effusive
statements of praise and affection
i will miss frank just like all of you
and i pray for the very best and all
good things for him
on the next part of his journey colby
who is obviously in the middle of
everything
hasn't had much to say about the changes
made around her workplace
until now that is she broke her silence
with a long emotional instagram post
she had a lot to say yet seemed to say
almost nothing of substance about the
interpersonal feud tearing apart her
show
unless you read between the lines she
rattles off a string of platitudes
without offering much contacts like
you can only be where you are sometimes
you just have to be okay with being
apart and
walk in peace and lead with love many
fans believe that the post is an
elliptical reference to all the behind
the scenes drama that has overwhelmed
her business and her
reality show most of the commentary is
big enough that fans can read into
whatever they want
that said colby's silence on the whole
shakeup has been deafening so this seems
like a potentially deft way to weigh in
without coming down hard on either side
the post appears as deeply personal as
it is vague she doesn't name any names
or state any specifics
so it's unclear whether she's talking
about herself or perhaps referencing the
rift between her co-stars
based on what we know about their split
though there are some inferences we can
make to bridge the gap between her words
and the situation
here's some of the missing contacts from
colby's post the sun also reported that
over the two years wolf and fritz
weren't speaking
many months of which were during the
height of the kobe 19 pandemic fritz was
admitted into rehab to combat a
substance abuse problem
he lost 65 pounds had serious back
surgery and is finally getting a leg up
on his crohn's disease
during all of that time though wolf
never bothered to reach out to check in
and see if he was okay these details
seem to frame wolfe as the villain of
this particular story
and many fans hope that colby's take
might clarify who's in the right and
who's in the wrong
that obviously didn't happen and the one
thing that remains true about this
interpersonal saga
is that we the public clearly don't have
a complete picture of the falling out
between these two friends
so is colby's post a letter to fritz
letting him know that he is still loved
even in his absence
or is it more of a goodbye encouraging
him to be strong on his own
even though he's no longer a part of the
show it's really hard to say
but her words seem kind and encouraging
so maybe there's hope to resolve things
and see both
men working together again even if fritz
only makes the occasional appearance in
lieu of returning as co-host
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
american pickers are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single
[Music]
one